how do you start a new language well
we're about to find out
because i'm starting a new language i'm
starting turkish
i'm going to show you how i do that it
started today this is actually when i'm
starting i started doing it this morning
we're now four in the afternoon
i've been to the gym i've been for
riding in my car so i've been listening
to some turkish i've spent a bit of time
on the first lesson
okay why suddenly turkish well i said
that you know i did arabic and farsi or
persian through the first three months
four months of the year
and then i was off to ukraine so i
worked a bit on my russian and ukrainian
and i was going to do
korean which i've done at different
times in the past and i wanted to just
improve my korean
but and i went to the korean and i did
korean for two three days
and finally i just found that my
motivation is not that great i i i
listen to a bit of persian while
preparing breakfast and i realize that
i'm slipping i'm forgetting
then i listen to some arabic i'm not
forgetting as much of my arabic because
i have spent more time listening to it
the more you listen the more you read
the less you're likely to forget so that
made me realize that i have to take my
persian and arabic further or i'm going
to slip back too much
and then i my wife watches turkish
cereals on netflix and i'm saying you
know what as i originally you know my
original motivation was sort of get into
that middle eastern central asian turkic
language persian arabic stuff so maybe i
should get into a new language turkish
so may not be the wisest thing to do
but um that's what i want to do
and so i'm going to show you how i
undertake a new language turkish i am
going to continue to do some maintenance
some listing and reading in arabic and
persian but i'm going to put a major
emphasis on trying to bring my
um
turkish up so
and i'm going to use
i'm going to demonstrate this on our
website on link and therefore i'm going
to use loom which is the software that
we use
to
demonstrate things
and we'll just see how it goes this is a
bit of an experiment but people always
ask me i say to learn a language you
have to listen and read people say yeah
but when you start in the language you
know nothing it's just noise how can you
start reading and listening i'm going to
demonstrate how you start in a language
a language which
is therefore
just noise to me
it's going to be easier than arabic and
persian because at least i can read the
latin based
alphabet
whereas with arabic and persian i had to
learn the writing system and
reading in a
strange writing system is always more
difficult i know
that within three months
i was able to become
sufficiently familiar with persian and
arabic that i started to make sense of
it as i listened and read i really
hadn't become you know a fluent speaker
or anything but i had been through that
that first phase that i talked about
where you become familiar with the
language in other words it's no longer
strange to you
and i'm going to show you now step by
step how that how i do that
in turkish so without further ado
i'll take you to my screen and link
here i am using loom
to uh project my screen uh onto this
video and it has my picture in the
corner
uh so this is what i look like on link
uh i have been focusing on the mini
stories
um
because i find them that's it's been my
experience it's the best place to start
i did poke around in the library and
found a newspaper article which is way
too difficult i found an easy
turkish
content item but i'm going to focus i
have been focusing on the many stories
because my experience
with the many stories in greek arabic
and persian is that it's the quickest
way to get immersed in the language
there's a lot of repetition in the
language in the stories and
through listening and reading i start to
acquire the language
so right away we can see that in this
series of of lessons 60 lessons in the
many stories
you know 95 of the words are blue
unknown to me
of course i don't know any turkish but i
have already created
122
links these are words that i have
decided to save
um
what else can i say 145 people have
liked stories in this course
so um
let's see what else if i look at what i
have done
yesterday
um i actually added 23 known words these
are words that probably repeated so
often
that i felt i got to know them i created
133 links
and
14 of them move to learn i listened for
half an hour
and i read 515 words so that's what i
did
yesterday so let's open it up and see
so
if i go to the first story now you'll
see that these stories have been added
to my playlist that means that i can
listen to them
i can listen to them
in the car uh i can listen to them on my
iphone on my ipad or at least my ipod
so i opened this one here which was the
first story that i did
and uh when i started of course
it was all meaningless to me
uh
but i now know that event means yes
and uh let's go actually to the
beginning of the story here
okay so you can't see it because my
my let's see we can move this guy over a
little bit
no so this is blocking it because i'm
running this loom so you see my picture
but
uh i'm looking at it you see i could
read the story
as a whole lesson
full text mode or full lesson page mode
but it's much more convenient to do it
um one lesson or one sentence at a time
in sentence mode
let's go to the next page and hope that
i'm not blocking here we are so i have
now learned that her means every
as in persian sabah means morning as in
persian as in arabic saad means our as
in persian and arabic altida i think
it's six or seven i can't remember six
okay
so i kind of know this one advantage of
being in sentence mode is that um
a lot of these stories in many languages
are time stamped so that john
you can hear the sentence in the natural
voice rather than text to speech the
individual words of course are text to
speech but you can hear the whole thing
in natural voice
um i've gone through and some of these
i've said i know john is the person in
the story every morning hour
six do i really know six
let's see
i've moved it to three i'm close to
saying that i know it
i may not do move there yet
uh wakes up
john gets up every morning at 6.
uh
i then very often
uh uh in an early i'm not a big user of
flashcards but early on when you have so
little traction in the language
you you read it and you don't understand
it uh looking at the words individually
is another form of exposure
and uh it's helpful in terms of getting
a handle on what these words are because
it's so it's so easy to forget them uh
in the early stages
so six yes i knew that i got it right
what else
again i know that i might get ah let's
move it to known
i know it i know it in context
so now i move to the second sentence now
you'll see up here
that going in sentence mode i've got a
lot of sentences to cover in this lesson
um
and again i can whoops start again i can
listen
now
i think is breakfast i'm fairly
confident of that let's move it to there
you see that the color gets lighter i
want my page to get lighter yapa is to
do make do as i remember
yep so makes breakfast
the is the same as in
and as in persian
this i think is coffee
coffee
i'm not worried at this point about
whether it's a direct object or the
subject of the sentence i just want to
get a sense of the words this is drink
i think i know each other i can move it
now
obviously
i'm dealing with a bunch of words here
and by the way i can listen
the interesting thing is i can listen to
the sentence and understand it because
i'm looking at it and i've looked up the
words and i can review the words in my
flashcards when i hear this on my
ipod or my iphone i still don't
understand okay so it's a constant
process
your brain has to gradually get used to
it when i i've now gone through the
first five lessons
and
i have
there are a few words that i pick up as
i listen if i go through you know
reading it and reviewing it i understand
more when i listen to it i don't
understand much but i start to hear a
few words it's like that jigsaw puzzles
certain elements are starting to appear
and i know from experience from my
experience with greek and persian and
arabic all of which are not written in
the latin alphabet that it's just a
matter of time before this starts to
become clearer to me
however it is useful to have a sense of
the grammar so
sort of an overview nothing too
complicated so what i typically do is
i go and i will google
now
at an initial stage i really only want
uh an overview
of the uh
i wonder why this is showing up like
this anyway
i really only want an overview
of the um
of the grammar
now here i am
so um i could uh you know
turkish basics that sounds pretty good
if i go there maybe that'll give me what
i want
yeah
so i am you are numbers you know it
gives you some sense let's see what they
have here
positive negative positive question
negative question you know
personal pronouns i am a doctor this
this is really all i want initially to
get just a beginning sense of how the
language works
but you know the interesting thing is if
again if i type in
turkish driver i mean there are pdf
files i can download there's a
tremendous amount of of resources out
there or if i wanted to
if i wanted to go turkish
uh nouns
you know if my curiosity is more on
nouns there's no shortage of material on
that as well so
whenever i'm curious about the grammar
uh i can go back in
and and uh
you know and search for it but right now
i just want an initial sort of rough
indication of how the grammar works my
main focus now
so i've done five stories
uh is to get where i can understand
those five stories i may stay on the
five although i have to admit that
i like i get enjoyment out of
i get enjoyment out of uncovering new
words so let's just go back
let's go to my lessons
and um okay
so uh where are your mini stories here i
don't think i did that as elegantly as i
could
but i can tell by the green light green
line here that these stories i have gone
through
story five so if story six i've just
started into it's a little bit of green
so
um i can open up
story six
and uh we'll wait for it here yeah
so um
i know our thoughts yeah this is
but
i like the idea that i'm uncovering
words so i'll go in there
their sons
oh letter
all
so yeah that doesn't make sense so i i
kind of saved that word yes
eat food so they make it here must mean
to eat let's see if i translate the
whole sentence okay i'm blocked but
their son eats with them
so i will continue doing this sort of as
far depending on my mood do i want to
under uncover more blue words at some
point i have to go back again
and when i am not in front of the
computer when i'm in the car or doing
the dishes or exercising i'm just
listening to these and while i'm
listening of course it's mostly
incomprehensible but i get better at
hearing the words i might hear onlala
or yemekir and i'll hear it but i won't
know what it means
and then i go back to reading it again
and so this is the constant process
whereby within a week or so
these stories start to have meaning
and
you know there are 60 stories if i can
cover the 60 stories in three months
on average that's 20 stories a month but
of course i will pick up more and more
words so i'll pick up speed so it's
possible that the first month i can only
do 10 or 15
and then the second month i'll do 20 and
then i'll go through the last 20 a lot
more quickly and so that i know from
experience that over three months
i will achieve that level of what i call
that first phase where the language is
no longer strange
uh i'm
sort of
starting to become familiar with the
language but i don't yet have a lot of
words
and but then i'm ready to embark on that
second very long stage where i start to
acquire more words that eventually take
me to this level of of comfort in the
language so that i can really start
enjoying
interesting content at any rate i am
excited about starting turkish i'm
excited about the connections to farsi
and arabic i'm excited about
getting into this part of the world and
and and
you know i should also mention by the
way that listening to things that i
don't understand is motivating to me
because it
it makes me want to look at it in link
and look up the words
but also one of my motivations for
learning turkish other than the
connection to arabic and persian is the
fact that my wife has been watching uh
turkish
serials or series you know soap operas
on netflix
and it's kind of motivating to see these
people speaking and you can't understand
what they're saying so that there are
many different things that might
motivate us to learn
to learn a language and basically it's a
matter of motivation and time so i know
from experience if i put in the time
doing this gradually bringing it into me
the language will become clearer and
then at some point i will have the urge
to speak but obviously right now
i don't understand
i can't speak so i have no interest in
connecting with a tutor now in three
months based on my experience with
persian and arabic i probably will want
to connect with a tutor so
there you have it i look forward to your
comments
and um
let me know what you think and if you're
interested in
you know continuing to follow my
progress in turkey well that's day one
on turkish uh
not well prepared but that's the way i
am that's how i go about these things
i'd be very interested in your reactions
uh questions about how this applies to
other languages questions about how you
approach say a language that you have
already been working at but sometimes
feel that you're not you know getting
where anywhere on or any other questions
and let me know if you're interested in
following my progress in turkish okay
bye for now
you